when you resigned your contract your
extension
i'm sure it was with this in mind
what could could you imagine it
happening for you the way that it
happened
no no no man
i i just i just i couldn't i could
i couldn't live you know there was there
was there was a job that had to be
finished
you know i feel like the bible did not
us justice you know give credit to miami
he
played great but he did not pay the
justice like everybody was feeling
homesick
we family oriented team wanted to sell
families
and and uh but you know coming back i
was like
this is my city you know they trust me
they believed in me
they believed in us even when we were
like we were lost the city still was
like
on our side and um
you know obviously i wanted to get the
job done
you know uh but that's my stubborn side
like it's easy to
go somewhere and go and win a
championship with somebody else
it's easy i could go i don't put anybody
in the spot but i could go to a super
team
and you know just do my part and win a
championship still one but this is the
hard way to do it and this is the way i
chose to do it
and we did it [ __ ] did it
we did it man jim on the front right